ez a keresztény történet hogy felveszed
a válladra a keresztet és viszed és és
ha azt a azt az üzenetet adod a
fiataloknak hogy figyeljetek az élet
nehéz nehéz lesz nektek is gyakorlatilag
körülöttetek mindenki meg fog öregedni
és meg fog halni és ti is és lehet hogy
ti hamarabb mint a környezetetek és és
azon kívül pedig bizonyos szempontból
igazságtalan a társadalom és egy csomó
mindent fog érni egy csalódás és
fájdalom és szenvedés az életbe de te
több vagy mint az a fájd képes vagy
felvenni a keresztedet és a benned levő
potenciál nagyobb hogyha figyelsz és
alázatos vagy akkor képes vagy
túlszárnyalni önként vállalva ezt a
szenved ez a keresztény történet